Can you recommend ingredients for a cancer patient that is dairy-free?
Ingredients for what?
So I'm very familiar with eating dairy-free. We have a lot of people in our family that are dairy-free for other reasons.
As far as a smoothie goes,
we never buy milk in our house, so we don't have any cow's milk.
What do we use to add to a smoothie? Well, personally, for me, for my smoothie, I don't add
any, quote, unquote, nut milk at all. My wife does. She likes coconut toasted coconut. I can't
remember the brand. It comes in a plastic bottle. It's toasted coconut, and they have an organic one of
those now. And that's what we use for a substitute for milk in our house. Like if we had a bowl of
granola cereal or something, I would use that toasted coconut. I think we're just used to that. To
be it, we haven't had dairy cows milk in our house for a decade or so or more. So my wife has been
dairy-free for a long time. So we would add that toasted coconut milk. I'm sorry, I can't tell you the
brand name of it. Maybe somebody else can remember if they think of that. If they use that same product,
that rings the bell. But that's what we use as far as adding to a smoothie. Now, other things that
you could add to a smoothie is coconut yogurt. So there are all the yogurts out there. There's coconut
yogurts out there. You could use that in a smoothie. That would be something. Forage your brand makes
and it makes probably the best quality yogurt. It's organic. Forage your brand. If you could get that
locally, they may have a vanilla and they have a played yogurt brand. I don't think they have
the berry. You don't have to add your own berries and stuff. But that's probably the best quality yogurt.
Thank you, Stacey. It is Khalifa Farms coconut milk. That's the one that is an organic coconut milk.
Toasted coconut milk. They have an organic almond milk. Both of those are good. Khalifa Farms.
They're getting to be a fairly big brand now. You can get them in most grocery stores now.
Comes in a plastic bottle. And then forage your brand is they make a sour cream. That's actually
pretty good. That's dairy free. They make a, and I believe that's organic. And they also make a
the yogurts that are organic. That's my daughter feeds my granddaughter. My two granddaughters and
her family just love that yogurt. So that's what they use typically. That Khalifa Farms also has a
coffee creamer or what it's worth. There's lots of other coffee creamers that are dairy free
out there too. But I like that brand Khalifa Farms. Can I chat in? Yeah. Can you hear me? Yes.
Because okay. Do you have any concern at all about all the gums in these non-dairy
milk and yogurt? Not really. Because you're not eating that much of it.
And yes, there could be some negatives to different gums. But a lot of them do act kind of like an
indigestible fiber. So you're not absorbing a lot of them. Now you can have sensitivities to
different gums. So if you use some of these products and you feel off at all in any way,
your gut feels off or you have any type of symptoms, brain fog or anything like that.
You can't have sensitivity. So the Cyrex Array 10 does test for different gums. So if you have
that thought process that you may have a sensitivity to that, then that's possible. I understand
everybody's a little bit different. But we buy a jug of that Khalifa Farms toasted coconut. And
typically we end up throwing part of it away because we just don't go through, you know, it's just
my wife and I at our house. So then the grandkids come over. They don't really use it that much.
So we don't really go through it. So it's not like we're consuming a lot of it.
But yeah, there is a possibility of having a sensitivity to those to anything really.
Anything you eat a lot of, you could develop a sensitivity too. So you do have to be aware of that.
Thank you.